there is a very sad column that just
came out from uma thurman terrific
actress uma thurman
who is attacking the pro-life law in
texas
and she's saying it's a human rights
crisis for american women and to make
her case she's coming out with news that
people did not know before which is
that she had an abortion she said she
started her acting career at 15 and she
was accidentally impregnated by a much
older man
she doesn't say she was
raped exactly she accidentally
impregnated
and
she was in living out of a suitcase in
europe far from her family about to
start a job
she struggled to know what to do i
wanted to keep the baby
but how
so she calls home
there's problems at home
the the family decided quote i couldn't
go through with the pregnancy and agreed
that termination was the right choice
my heart was broken nonetheless
okay
there's so much pain in this story she
writes it's been my darkest secret until
now i'm 51 years old i'm sharing it with
you from the home where i've raised my
three children who are my pride and joy
the abortion i had as a teenager was the
hardest decision in my life one that
caused me anguish then and that saddens
me even now but it was the path to the
life full of joy and love that i've
experienced choosing not to keep that
early pregnancy allowed me to grow up
and become the mother i wanted and
needed to be
so the obvious question that comes from
this
why was it so sad why does it sadden you
even now why did it break your heart
because
you killed your child that's why and
a lot of women do it and a lot of women
don't know what they're doing at the
time and especially if you're 15 years
old you might be very confused
especially if your family is telling you
to kill this child especially if the
whole culture's telling you to kill this
child but deep down you know what it is
and you know that that gnaws at you and
that's deeply saddening and especially
in a world that doesn't recognize the
possibility of redemption
this is going to eat away at you forever
and ever of course she didn't need to
kill a baby she could have given the
baby up for adoption there are many many
couples who want to adopt children many
more couples who want to adopt little
babies than little babies who are put up
for adoption but then listen to this
line she goes
she says uh you know the the life full
of joy and love that i've experienced
was caused
and it was enabled because i had this
abortion you heard this from another
actress some years ago i forget her name
she said i won this gold statue because
i had an abortion i couldn't have done
it if i hadn't had an abortion
sacrificing your children to gold idols
is nothing new that is actually the
default state of human nature and
judaism you know the ancient israelites
and then christianity in in its
fulfillment come about and say don't do
that stop doing that okay
we are now reverting to that society is
going to have some religion or another
which one do you want to have do you
want to have the religion that seems a
little kooky with the smells and the
bells and the crucifixes and the little
liturgies or do you want to have the
religion that is much kookier where the
high priests are people like dr fauci
and where the high sacraments are child
sacrifice which which you're going to
have some religion which one do you want
to live under i'm glad you like that
clip here's what i need you to do i need
you not only to subscribe to the michael
noel show channel here on youtube i need
you to go to apple podcasts or spotify
or stitcher wherever you get your
podcasts type in
the michael knowles show it's very easy
to type in mich ael know wlas type it in
subscribe leave a five star review we
really appreciate you see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you